كان هذا ممنوعًا في الساعة الخامسة من
صباح يوم الثلاثاء ،
لكن سمح به بحلول الظهر ، كان محظورًا
يوم الجمعة عند شروق الشمس
ولكن حسنًا بحلول غروب الشمس إذا لم يكن
الأمر محبطًا ومحزنًا ،
فقد أصبح من المضحك أن قيود فيروس كورونا في إسرائيل
أصبحت مجموعة مختلطة
من القواعد التي في بعض الأحيان
التغيير بالساعة يقول إيتامار نافون إنه
مصمم على فتح مطعم
منى الخاص به حتى لو كان ذلك يعني تحديًا
صريحًا للقيود الحكومية الأخيرة ،
فهو يريد حلاً طويل الأجل وليس
قواعد وأنظمة خليط ،
فنحن رجال أعمال نعرف كيف
نعمل أعمالنا.  تعرف على كيفية حساب
نماذجنا
ولكننا بحاجة إلى بعض الإجابات التي لا يمكننا الحصول
عليها من أن الحكومة
تلعب معنا طوال اليوم
ويشعر حقًا أنهم يلعبون معنا
ويلعبون مع بعضهم البعض
بدلاً من أخذ هذه الأزمة على محمل الجد
أصدرت الحكومة تعليمات للمطاعم
بإغلاق صباح يوم الثلاثاء ، وهو قرار
تم التراجع عنه بعد ساعات قليلة في الجلسة
مع بعض المشرعين قائلين إن البيانات أظهرت أن
المطاعم ليست  المصدر الرئيسي
للعدوى
، حاول رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
أن يُظهر أنه مسؤول
عن قيادة البلاد خلال
أزمة فيروس كورونا ،
ولكن في خضم تزايد
الحالات الجديدة المؤكدة ، تراجعت ثقة الجمهور
في أطول زعيم في إسرائيل في الخدمة ،
فقد كان بابًا دوارًا
للاحتجاجات في الخارج.  مقر إقامة رئيس الوزراء
هنا في القدس ، هناك
احتجاجات الراية السوداء ضد الفساد
، الاحتجاجات الاقتصادية ضد
تعامل الحكومة مع أزمة فيروس كورونا ،
رأينا
احتجاجات مؤيدة للضم ضد الضم
، والآن هناك
احتجاجات لأصحاب المطاعم للتعبير
عن إحباطهم من
تعامل الحكومة مع جميع أصحاب هذا
المطعم بإعداد وجبات الطعام من
فائض مخزونهم الغذائي الذي يقولون إنه كان سيتم
التخلص منه لولا ذلك
بسبب القواعد المتغيرة حول
المطاعم ، والفكرة الكامنة وراء ذلك هي أن
الحكومة والدولة لا
تعتني بالناس
ثم بدلاً من مجرد رمي الطعام
بعيدًا ،
فإننا ج  فقط تخدمها للأشخاص الذين
لا يستطيعون تحمل تكاليفها لأنفسهم في هذا
الموقف الذي نواجهه الآن في
البلد ، انتشر الارتباك إلى ما وراء
المطبخ ، وبدأت لجنة Knesset الخاصة
للتعامل مع فيروس
كورونا بهدف بسيط ،
دعونا نعطي القواعد التي  الجمهور قادر
على فهم ما
قيل ولكن انتهى به الأمر إلى إحداث مزيد من الارتباك
حول ما هو مفتوح وما هي
القيود بسبب الخلافات الرئيسية
بين لجنة كنسيت والحكومة
الكثير من حمامات السباحة والصالات الرياضية في شواطئ البلاد
وأكثر من ذلك كله
عالق في هذا النسيان من القيود
وارن ليبرمان سيينا  القدس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أوه